-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope
you're doing well tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
When asked during an interview
last week
about the national mood,
President Biden said,
"People are
really, really down,"
even though he did everything
he could to make us smile.
[ Laughter ]
After falling off his bike over
the weekend, President Biden
did a brief dance
after leaving church
to show reporters
he was feeling fine.
Though, just for the record,
we stopped associating dancing
with good health some time ago.
[ Laughter ]
Members of the House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
are reportedly considering
issuing a subpoena
to former Vice President
Mike Pence.
Good luck. If those lips were
any tighter, they'd seal over.
[ Laughter ]
Sunday was Father's Day,
and what's nicer to hear
after "I love you"
than "Thanks"?
[ Laughter ]
And ex-aide to
former President Trump
revealed in a new interview that
while watching President Biden
on TV, Trump blurted out, "Can
you believe I lost to this guy?"
"Been there," said one woman.
[ Laughter ]
After last week's televised
hearings on the Capitol attack,
former President Trump
said on Friday
that ex-Vice President
Mike Pence
did not have the courage to act
on January 6th and added,
"Mike was afraid of
whatever he was afraid of."
Um, getting hanged?
You can't threaten to kill a man
and then ask
what he's so scared of.
That's like Jason saying,
"What?! What did I do?"
According to a new report,
Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker
has fathered three children he
has not publicly acknowledged,
or, as his opponent thinks
of it, three more votes!
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times"
recently published an article
about so-called "peecyclers"
who recycle their urine
to use as fertilizer.
I don't know.
I think if that worked,
the subway would look like this.
[ Laughter ]
Today, June 21st,
is the longest day of the year.
That's right -- One of my kids
has a piano recital.
[ Laughter ]
An anonymous bidder
recently paid over $19 million
for a private lunch
in New York City
with up to seven guests
and investor Warren Buffett.
And I can guess what Buffett's
first investment tip will be.
[ Light laughter ]
I guess I'm the only one
that can guess.
[ Laughter ]
Not one of you
has the same guess as me?!
[ Laughter ]
He's got -- [ Laughs ]
I mean, it's just, like, jarring
to go "oh" for the room.
[ Laughter ]
He's gonna come in
and he's gonna be like,
"$19 million is too much
to pay for lunch."
[ Laughter ]
[ Pencil snaps ]
Ah-ah-ha! Ha-ha! Ha-ha!
[ Applause ]
The toy company Nerf recently
unveiled its first-ever mascot,
which is a character
named Murph,
though it's hard to imagine that
children will have the energy
to play with Nerf products since
they will never sleep again!